les bandas ce emblème absolu du pays
basque rythme la fête du piment
d'espelette
les spl attaque hobby pétards comme on
dit ici un piment rapportés par les
conquistadors espagnols après la
conquête de l'amérique centrale est
aujourd'hui chacun fait son marché
l'envers du décor des champs de piment
tout autour du village
cette culture en pleine expansion
s'étale sur les trois quarts de l'année
et constitue une bonne activité
complémentaire pour une petite
exploitation agricole
en attendant peut être mieux les
familles peuvent vivre à l'aise bien
qu'avec des paiements mais il fait faire
une quantité suffisante aux alentours de
60 mille pieds et avec ça je pense
qu'ils pouvaient tout se passe donc en
famille et le plus souvent dans la salle
à manger de la ferme chaque piment et
méticuleusement triés par formes tailles
et qualité avant d'être placés sur des
cordes puis il sèche durant plusieurs
semaines sur les façades des maisons
basques avant un séjour de quelques
heures dans un four à pain ce pin ont
été rentrées la foule ce matin vers 4h
de ce vin pour quand
mais on les ressent l'humidité
résiduelle en france 8
il fera passer par un concasseur pour
être broyés une poudre de piment utilisé
comme du poivre pour relever le goût de
la shoah le plat d'espelette qui mélange
vos oignons et piment bien sûr rapport à
l'image du bilan humain toujours cayenne
très fort très piquant dirais qu'il est
simplement gentiment piquant c'est que
doubler un petit peu de chaleur dans le
palais mais quand quelque chose
d'agréable vous n'êtes pas du feu outre
après midi mais là surtout du goût et du
parfum
en attendant les producteurs du pays
basque souhaite la mise en place d'une
appellation d'origine contrôlée que se
laisse palette cartes sont libres